here's the issue though you know we had
ron perlman he's the celebrity who
played hellboy come out recently and say
republican states should leave and we
should leave and this discussion about
national divorce has been on for a long
time but what people don't understand is
that's exactly what happened in the
first civil war it wasn't like you had
all of the states fighting in congress
and then also and started shooting each
other in fact what actually happened
first was several states said we out and
they went okay bye and then i actually
pulled up from the library of congress
in january of 1861 you had 11 states
succeeding to form the confederacy and
lincoln hadn't even been inaugurated
until march yeah it wasn't until the
south started seizing forts
that the north said hey you can't do
this so what would happen in the event
of a national divorce sure you know
california illinois
new york might be like we're going to
canada or something
but then all of a sudden you're going to
have
one state's got a nuclear arsenal
and they're going to say we're the true
government of the united states of
america and those nukes belong to us and
then uh
one of these states is whichever faction
is in control of dc or whatever they're
going to say no it's ours you can't take
it and we're going to then you know
relocate these weapons and that's that's
basically what happened with fort sumter
let me give two examples of of
successful secession
in history that everybody knows about
and everybody forgets about and once
very specific to your case
ukraine used to be part of the soviet
union
and they left there was there were a lot
of uh
of those
well i mean the soviet union collapsed
so did it i mean wouldn't you wouldn't
the soviet union call it a collapse if
america was sort of fragmented they
would look at us and say oh your federal
government got so unwieldy that's true
and you overextended your federal
reserve and your army and you collapsed
under your own weight and now you're
separate states that's true okay so it's
been done there but it's also been done
in the united states there's one example
and i was born in the state that seceded
that nobody talks about and ex
successfully seceded west virginia
excuse me june of june of 1861 residents
of the western counties of virginia did
not wish to secede along with the rest
of the state this section of virginia
was admitted into the union as a state
of west virginia on june 20th 1863. so
they separate they seceded from the
confederacy
and but to do so they had to split a
state in half
and it's been totally accepted we go on
with life as if it's normal that a state
just said you know we're going to
separate they didn't go back together
when when virginia came back into the
union so a state has separate a state
has seceded from a state it's happened
what about north and south carolina
north and south dakota were they once
dakota and carolina
no yeah i think they were always maybe
territories for a brief moment gotcha
but i don't i don't think i think it's
naive to believe that the united states
is always going to exist in these
perfect 50 states under this you know
under the federal government that keeps
expanding and expanding and expanding
and i think it's irrational for people
to think that americans are just going
to sit idly by while our federal
government completely becomes tyrannical
and out of control like we've watched it
do over the past year and
no one wants violence and i'll say again
i'm completely against the civil war
even though the media tries to say i say
things like that i never do but i do
truly believe that if this becomes such
a broken nation
and we have one party that is trying to
rule over like the democrats are trying
to rule over republicans to the point
where they are deciding what opinion we
are allowed to say whether we can get
whether we can stay on social media or
we have to leave because we're spreading
what they claim is misinformation if
they get to a point where they're saying
we're going to control your um what
you're allowed to do with your body and
and what you have to have injected into
your body and you have no no choice or
say they're coming to the point where
they're saying this is what your
children have to be taught and parents
you have no input or say and your and
your children essentially belong to the
state like some people are actually
saying out loud and that's happening in
the state of california and elsewhere
when it gets to that point
it you can't you can't just accept or
think that americans are going to accept
it that is when it's okay to start
saying you know what just like in a
marriage i don't like the way you're
treating me you you either have to
change i'm asking you to change which is
what republicans should be saying to
democrats right now stop this behavior
you have to change we all have to live
here together we should care about our
country together and if you're not then
we need to consider maybe we need to
separate and what does that look like
but if there's one thing i think we've
learned it's that the left absolutely
believes it should rule over the right
exactly and that's just authoritarianism
in general this idea of a leftist this
weird authoritarian bent whatever the
libertarian side of things are the
freedom which includes a large faction
of people they're basically saying leave
me alone i'll go do my thing leave me
alone but they're saying no i'm not
going to leave you alone you're going to
do as you're told or else yeah
that doesn't sound like you can have a
peaceful divorce i mean you've got a
husband and a wife and the wife's saying
i want to leave and the husband's like
don't you dare or else i mean you need
more than just a court order you're
going to need police intervention and
protections
so
maybe you know when you see people like
ron perlman when you see like john
podesta and donna brazile in that 2020
scenario they did with the boston globe
reported on where they advocated western
state secede from the union if donald
trump wins the election again
maybe they will be willing to say fine
we're out right i will i will tell you
what i love the most about this trope is
the the the urban the city urban liberal
types are convinced that they will
flourish and the red states and
republicans will suffer and i'm like
do you know how to
take care of chickens for instance where
do you get your food from oh your
avocados from mexico were shipped into
your win in the middle of winter and
you're having strawberries and avocado
your strawberry yogurt with your
avocados yeah okay if you don't know how
to grow your own food if you don't know
how to and it's not even about growing
your own food we learned this lesson we
planted you probably understand this we
planted all the tomatoes at once and
that's a big mistake
you plant them one week at a time so
that they the tomatoes ripen not all at
once otherwise you're eating 50 tomatoes
all at once we didn't know that because
we're a bunch of city folks who moved
out to the middle of nowhere
but the people who live in these cities
they get their food shipped in they do
jobs like
writing at buzzfeed or working for you
know bureaucratic firms or
administrative firms or managerial firms
they're not the ones that for the most
part are making the machine churn
so in the event there was a major
divorce i don't think city i think
cities are going to just implode they're
going to go nuts yeah well tim what
you're not factoring in is that all of
those blue states have the reddit
moderators who walk dogs for 25 hours a
week and i don't know that we could
stand to lose them in all seriousness
in all seriousness one of the the issues
and this isn't just a problem with
national divorce or the the union
remaining together or whatever the
alternative is here
it's just an issue of the full like the
philosophical differences between left
and right here at least as they exist
today it's not so much that right
leaning people are all saying
i want to mind my own business i want
you to mind your own business there's
certainly that faction on the right but
even the right leaning people who would
like to see stronger government action
tend to be much more in favor of local
solutions whereas with left-wing people
they feel this unquenchable desire to
change things unbelievably far away from
them that they have no business meddling
in while problems fester all over their
own community and part of it is because
i believe that those external problems
are much more abstract and these are
people who aren't really interested in
engaging with reality and it feels
really good to say i'm going to effect
change and make the world better without
actually doing anything in your own
local community and so they end up
voting for policies that will affect the
way other people live their lives
without making any personal sacrifices
of their own and so whether we have a
national divorce whether the country
stays together that tendency is not
going to change with those people i've
got another potential solution than
national divorce as a solution to like
the corruption the revolving door of
people coming out people getting bribed
maybe we can set up a direct republic
right now i've for a long time i've been
thinking i thought i don't think we need
the house of representatives you talked
to mike revell and he wanted to set up
what's called the national initiative
the idea that every american citizen has
the right to write laws and pass it into
the senate and we would all create our
own representative from our state so
we'd have 50 representatives of national
initiative we in his world we still have
the house of representatives but i see
them getting bribed and they're it's a
it's a vulnerability in the system what
if it was a smart contract and all of
the representatives these 800 000 people
vote for the way they want their
contract to act while it's in service
and as long as it's there it's just
voting yay or nay as the populist
directs it i find the notion of going to
more of i know you call it a republic
but more of a democratic type solution
terrifying well i would call a direct
republic it's actually less of a
democratic solution or it's equally
democratic let me let me uh be fair and
condemn my uh colleagues at the same
time
you know i don't blame aoc for what she
does i don't
95 percent of my colleagues i don't
question their motives or blame them for
their behavior even though it's wrong
most of the time i blame the people that
voted for them they're actually
responding to the people that elected
them that's that's even as you can say
all you want about the lobbyists and the
money and i have talked about how the
committees are messed up that way but
the individuals who get elected are
fairly
reflective what bothers me is when they
say when you vote for me i'm going to
say yes to dog walkers and then they get
in they're like i'm going to vote no on
that
what recourse do i have now it's a voter
i already this is what i chose yeah well
i think everyone in the house every two
years you could throw them out that is
true we have to get elected every two
years
today's age two years is forever it's so
long but hold on hold on so so much
now when you get a ron paul i mean how
many terms did he serve he served a lot
well if he was there for a long time he
served for a while and then he came back
in like 96 because he he
he got
dis and he you know disillusioned didn't
think it was fixable but my
understanding is came back after he ran
for president my understanding is the
reason he won is because people really
like him
right is that
is that true i don't live in his
district so was it that people just vote
republican it didn't matter it was ron
paul
the reason most people win is people
like them
you nancy pelosi
they like her oh they love her san
francisco
they love her in san francisco you know
i'd like to think that people elect an
ideology or or uh but in reality they
look for people they like they do you
it's there's nothing to like about you
know i i i marjorie i think you're
correct we just can't live with these
people anymore if they like nancy pelosi
and find something good in her i'm just
lost i don't i don't know i'm joining my
maybe i must find the love for all
humans i have a second thing
can i i can't understand that world if i
just can't i just want to throw one more
thing in here about national divorce i
sort of mentioned that even if we break
up the the federal government even if
all the states go their separate way one
group is still going to have a desire to
control and obviously they couldn't do
that the federal government at that
point but when you look at so much of
the actual censorship that the american
people are facing it's coming from large
corporations and that kind of thing is
always going to be weaponized i mean
national divorce or not it would depend
on your states and how they're set up
but here's something here's a second
thing that i think everyone should think
about while we're fighting out our
differences here in the united states
and among one another as americans
the biggest thing that upsets me is as
americans we aren't coming together as a
whole and saying we can put aside our
petty differences in our opinions what
we should be standing together on is we
should be standing against china we
should be standing against globalism
because if you want to talk about
authoritarianism and you want to talk
about people that really want to rule
over us china is a direct threat to our
entire existence and let me tell you
something else china is embedded in the
united states there are politicians
people that thomas thomas and i work
with that are completely sold out i if
you have not read peter schweitzer's
book the new book that has come out i
highly encourage you to read it you
would be shocked there's a there's a
whole whole chapter on dianne feinstein
that woman has been there probably
longer than all of us have been alive
they have made so much money through
corporate connections um policy
deals that she was willing to make
through her powerful position as a
senator
with her husband stock deals
money investments i mean it is it is
outrageous that this actually happened
but it's not just them it's happened
over and over and over again with people
in power right here in our country and
this is the kind of thing that i think
we should come together on thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you